[Applaudissements]
allez les chéris on va revenir sur ce
qui a fait énormément parler cette
histoire on va passer à la mise au point
on va évoquer ces révélations qu'on
provoqué un coup de tonnerre dans le
milieu du sport l'entraîneur du PSG
Christophe galti et
accusé d'avoir tenu des propos lorsqu'il
était entraîneur de l'OGC Nice la saison
dernière
un petit peu limite un mail accablon
était révélé par un journaliste dans
lequel l'ancien directeur sportif du
club évoque des propos à caractère
raciste qui aurait été tenus par
Christophe Galtier alors je vous le dis
moi un mail le truc d'un pote d'un mec
qui aurait fait un mail etc moi aussi il
y a plein de gens qui disent des choses
sur moi par mail les trucs moi je veux
les preuves je veux les trucs je vous le
dis voilà on verra bien mais on va voir
on va faire alors je vais alors je sais
pas le récap que vous avez fait là c'est
quoi le recap là parce que si c'est pour
quoi
de manière factuelle et neutre vous êtes
sûr bon on va le voir
si je vois qu'il n'est ni factuel ni
l'autre je l'arrêterai au milieu vous le
savez non mais je vous le dis un mec qui
aurait dit que ma mère a vu mon père en
train de me mettre des voilà non mais je
vous dis arrêter c'est bon là
on va voir ça on va en parler dans un
instant non mais c'est bon aussi on a
dit qu'on m'avait vu en train de voler
des Kickers dans un magasin de
chaussures
mais d'un gars voilà donc on va en
parler parce qu'il faut en parler mais
on va voilà et puis surtout en fait
c'est surtout pour inviter Daniel Riolo
parce qu'il va nous parler d'autre chose
aussi de son livre où là il y a de
vraiment des choses très intéressantes
dans l'île de Daniel Riolo voilà et pour
l'instant on va voir ça après il y a
chacun voit midi à sa porte c'est parti
attention
si Christophe Galtier a repris les
rennes du PSG depuis 2022 si j'ai
accepté de prendre ses responsabilités
là c'est que j'en suis capable il était
au cours de la saison précédente
entraîneur de l'OGC Nice
une saison sur la Côte d'Azur au cours
de laquelle il a collaboré avec l'ancien
directeur sportif du club Julien
Fournier avec qui il s'est brouillé et
l'homme l'accuserait aujourd'hui d'avoir
tenu des propos déplacés et même
racistes à l'encontre de ses joueurs à
travers un mail qui aurait fuité des
gens en septembre dernier Julien
Fournier c'était montré enigmatique au
sujet de Christophe Galtier il explique
les vraies raisons pour lesquelles
Christophe et moi on s'est disputé
rentrera plus dans un vestiaire des
accusations qu'il contestent fermement
alors révélations sur fond de racisme
contre l'entraîneur du PSG Christophe
Galtier que sait-on
Daniel Riolo est avec nous on va pas
être chaos Football Club c'est le livre
de Daniel Riolo avec Abdelkrim Brahim ça
les choses si très intéressantes donc
comment ça va mon Daniel déjà très bien
de toi que moi après c'est un truc de
fou c'est où Daniel Riolo c'est un truc
de fou Géraldine en fait le soir
c'est incroyable pas se balader dans la
rue c'est où Hanouna voyons
moi c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien parce que tu vois voilà
et on le dit et Daniel et moi on n'est
pas d'accord sur plein de trucs mais ça
nous permet on s'aime quand même hein
c'est rien ça bah oui voilà
et c'est ça voilà mais ça sert à rien ça
voilà on a la garde partagée
parler de cette histoire depuis cet été
puis cet été on est les mecs du foot
m'avaient dit il y a un truc comme quoi
Fournier ancienne adjoint de Galtier on
l'avait entendu Raymond on était
ensemble ah voilà on se dit voilà et on
disait ça va il s'arrête ça va sortir ça
va sortir ça va sortir pourquoi
maintenant ah le maintenant parce que le
mail je l'ai reçu dimanche matin
d'accord c'est toi et donc c'est que
possible il est fort probable que samedi
soir il y avait le PSG qui jouait à Nice
ça s'est mal passé à la fin histoire de
la banderole en brouille entre un joueur
égality il est possible que c'est
raviver certaines tensions et que les
gens qui avaient ce mail dans
l'entourage du club se sont dit tiens on
va le balancer à quelques journalistes
je l'ai eu d'autres d'autres l'ont eu en
revanche ce qu'il faut c'est j'ai lu sur
les réseaux sociaux et limite à un
moment j'ai cru que c'était moi le
coupable ouais vous avez caché ça tout
le monde était au courant depuis non non
ce dont on était au courant c'était des
rumeurs un journaliste de rumeurs il
n'en refait rien il peut enquêter
demander mais quand les gens ne veulent
pas parler on va pas les forcer à parler
là je reçois le mail le mail il y a il y
a pas l'en-tête il y a pas il y a juste
on comprend que c'est adressé par
l'ancien directeur sportif à Dave Brest
fort qui est l'anglais qui dirige le
groupe ineoction on comprend ça mais moi
avec ça qu'est-ce que je peux faire rien
ces paroles contre parole c'est ça
l'autre va dire que c'est pas vrai donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans un premier
temps on contacte celui qui a écrit le
mail
qui finit par nous dire oui oui c'est
bien moi qui l'ai écrit là ça devient
autre chose si il dit je l'ai écrit
d'abord pourquoi tu l'as écrit est-ce
que c'est vrai ce que tu as écrit
forcément il va y avoir le contre-champ
à savoir galti on s'attendait évidemment
à ce qu'il dit c'est pas vrai j'ai pas
dit ça nous on a pas le contexte de
comment il a dit ça sauf que le mail il
est quand même super lourd c'est pas
juste j'ai dit ah bah tiens il y a trop
d'arabe dans le vestiaire une phrase
comme ça hors contexte
dans le chaud il y a beaucoup de degrés
quand même et dans le mail les degrés on
les explose hein parce que le mec le mec
il fait mais c'est pas en tête le nombre
de pages mais il est long il est long le
mail c'est pas
juste une phrase comme ça ou des beautés
il y en a beaucoup des phrases donc au
bout d'un moment on est bien obligé de
s'arrêter là-dessus et moi ce qui m'a ce
qui commence à m'agacer vraiment c'est
que moi maintenant j'aimerais bien que
tous ceux qui se planquent en off et ben
il part il commence à parler parce que
moi je veux bien Nice le Président je
suis pas au courant président de quoi
alors tu es président de quoi il y a ton
entraîneur et ton directeur sportif se
mettent sur la gueule et pas pour des
broutilles pour quelques pour une
affaire qui va devenir très très grave
mais toi tu es au courant de rien et
INEO ce mec a reçu le mail qui a fait il
a pris il a mis la poubelle il y a pas
de réaction il y a pas vous étiez au
courant aussi pas au courant et les
joueurs les joueurs l'adjoint de Galtier
l'année dernière parent-ils très choqué
il dit à des journalistes en off les
joueurs aujourd'hui moi j'entends des
joueurs ça m'arrive aux oreilles je suis
vraiment super content que ça sorte
enfin parce que vraiment c'était dur bah
oui ouvre ta gueule alors pourquoi tu le
dis pas personne
vous dites pas quand il faut dire
pourquoi vous dites maintenant et vous
le dites pas un autre moment pourquoi
ben ouais à un moment et c'est ils
veulent quoi les gens veulent quoi les
journalistes ne disent plus jamais rien
parce qu'après on est attaqué
immédiatement on attaque en diffamation
il faut aller au tribunal pour se
défendre alors si les gens veulent pas
parler bah à un moment on dira plus rien
parce que Jacques les joueurs ne veulent
plus parler ils communiquent que par un
réseau sociaux bientôt quand on va
servir c'est quand on parle on est
accusé de parler c'est ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu ce mail
maintenant on verra on verra mais c'est
vrai que derrière et je le dis personne
n'a confirmé qui va confirmer Cyril
voilà il y a Christophe Gallier qui a
dit qui a dit que c'est pas vrai alors
je te le dis je le cache pas ici
Christophe voilà je suis quelqu'un qui
je m'entends très bien et d'ailleurs je
lui demanderai à l'occasion voilà je te
le dis je lui demanderai je vais je
l'appellerai pour lui demander et voilà
et et de ce qu'il me dit et de ce que
j'ai entendu il me dit voilà il me dit
que c'est voilà il s'était fortement
brouillé et il savait qu'elle allait
avoir un truc et qu'ils allaient essayer
de voilà le mec avec certains joueurs le
mettre dans la soie il y a des gens qui
ne voulaient plus du tout jouer à Nice
et qui ont voulu partir amine Wery a
voulu partir
todibo qui avait été approché par le PSG
a dit moi j'y vais jamais si c'est lui
l'entraîneur il y a quand même pas mal
de joueurs mais juste Daniel parce que
bon tu le sais moi aussi voilà je suis
fan du PSG je suis assez pote c'est avec
les dirigeants du PSG dirigeants du PSG
quand ils ont pris Galtier six mois j'ai
les rumeurs sur un truc voilà qui
tournerait
là-dessus sur un truc qui serait passé
dans les vestiaires etc
ils ont entendu comme toi ils ont
téléphoné à Nice à Nice non c'est bon
bah oui voilà l'autre il a dit non c'est
bon bah donc hop c'est ça
débarrasser de lui ils ont voulu plus
donc c'est ce que tu dis c'est ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure c'est que tant que
les mecs là pour l'instant il n'y a pas
un mec de Nice ou un mec du vestiaire le
mail il existe les propos étaient
racontés mais honnêtement même si moi je
veux régler mes comptes avec quelqu'un
c'est dur d'aller balancer
mais il y a quand même ces détails il y
a des dates et tout je veux bien régler
mes comptes mais si je règle mes comptes
je fais une page si c'est que ça si je
suis que malveillant là c'est quand même
bien argumenté c'est quand même bien
mais je ne peux pas me prononcer
effectivement il y a un mail nous là il
y a un mec qui va forcément un gars qui
va dire c'est pas vrai c'est que c'est
que du mytho et maintenant on verra mais
non en tout cas on est arrivé le truc
est-ce que le fait que personne ne parle
montre pas justement que ce sont que des
rumeurs que c'est peut-être exagéré
déformé du coup Guillaume tu sais
pourquoi il parle pas tu sais pourquoi
il parle pas les mecs et les gens ils
veulent voir pas ça va nous créer des
emmerdes pour ton contrat dans le club
tu seras pas repris dans ce club là
parce que tu seras le mec qui aura
balancé c'est l'omerta dans le foot les
mecs disent rien et mecs ne veulent pas
parler et vois ce que vous pensez que
c'est pas que c'était trop tôt pour
balancer ce mail même si tourner un peu
sur les réseaux sociaux
on va rappeler ce qu'il y a dans le mail
hein bah on aura jamais plus de preuves
que ça il y a un mail mais s'il y a des
gens qui nous le seul truc qu'on voulait
savoir c'est ce qu'il avait réellement
été écrit par cette personne à partir du
moment où la personne me dit oui c'est
moi qui écris le mail que si tu veux que
j'ai pas mais est-ce que ça suffit pour
mettre quelqu'un dans une polémique
comme ça parce que la carrière d'un
homme là bien sûr alors ça je te dis je
ne te dis pas que ça a pas été quelque
chose d'assez compliqué et dont on a
parlé entre nous moi je vous dis pour
moi ça c'est c'est compliqué parce que
tu peux dire ce qu'il y a dans le
meilleur en substance oui voilà ça après
je vous dis moi j'ai eu des voilà j'ai
un peu enquêté on m'a dit vraiment que
c'était aussi voilà c'est fortement
exagéré que c'est des gros règlement de
compte voilà mais dis-nous alors ça
raconte des propos tenus par le fils de
Christophe Galtier qui est aussi son
agent et par Christophe Galtier donc
c'est exactement donc en gros Galtier
dit que il se reconnaît pas du tout dans
l'équipe de Nice telle qu'elle est avec
des joueurs noirs des joueurs musulmans
ça ne correspond pas à la ville dit-il
selon donc Julien Fournier qui était le
directeur sportif il faut rappeler
qu'ils sont qui sont en guerre ils sont
en guerre la guerre ouverte
aujourd'hui ils se sont brouillés à
cause de ça voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
peut se demander si les mails ne sort
pas un moment opportun au moment où
Galtier est fragilisé également voilà ça
c'est une question mais dans le mail il
dit que l'équipe de Nice ne correspond
ni à la ville ni à lui-même voilà et
globalement il se plaint du fait que des
joueurs fassent le ramadan qui est trop
pour schématiser trop de noir et trop de
musulmans dans les qu'est-ce qui va se
passer maintenant Daniel
encore une fois je te le redis
j'aimerais bien que parce que là sinon
ça va être lui il a parlé lui il a dit
c'est pas vrai alors j'aimerais que
certains joueurs sortent du bois et
disent ce qu'ils ont réellement vécu
l'année dernière et qu'il nous disent
qu'elles ont été les épisodes qu'il
compte qu'il confirme ça parce que nous
il nous le disent
s'il le disent là pour le coup peut être
puisque c'est du Off je vais pas les
balancer le nom ça je peux pas le faire
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs à un moment dans
le livre cette histoire de off et des
mecs qui veulent pas parler dans le foot
franchement c'est exaspérant au bout on
a rencontré
80 témoins sur toutes les histoires et
les affaires qu'on a dans le bouquin au
bout du 5e moi j'en ai eu marre les mecs
c'était non moi je te raconte tout mais
je balance jamais mon nom et toi si tu
veux que les choses avancent il y a une
seule personne qui a parlé pas à moi
directement elle a parlé à la justice
elle a eu le courage c'est pas le Pogba
la pression était devenue trop forte
autour de lui je rappelle pas la faire
vous l'avez même parler ici l'année
dernière le mec quand même séquestré
racketté lui il est allé à la police
mais quand est jamais allé Matuidi à
l'époque n'est jamais allé tous ces
entourages tous ces gens qui gravitent
autour parce que en fait nous ce qu'on
raconte dans le bouquin c'est que il y a
un gros gâteau et tout le monde veut
croquer dans ce gâteau du football dans
cette somme faramineuse que peuvent
représenter les joueurs les transferts
bah alors comme je répète
qui veut se dévoiler ça c'est exaspère
tu parles de Killian Mbappe et de sa
famille qui veulent être au centre de
tout au sujet de chamer tu dis je
remarque chez elle une sorte de
déconnexion du réel une volonté de tout
contrôler de croire que son fils vient
d'une autre planète footballistique le
clan Mbappé veut être au centre de tout
aujourd'hui effectivement la question
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que c'est
elle qui dirige réellement le
Paris-Saint-Germain c'est ce qu'on et
c'est ce qu'on voit la semaine dernière
l'épisode oui avec la campagne de
promotion ah ben non mais je je
désolidarises complètement de cette
campagne de réabonnement alors c'est je
ne veux pas être le Killian
Saint-Germain mais en même temps bah je
le suis quand même puisque en gros je
dis que les mecs qui communiquent dans
mon club font ça n'importe comment après
oui elle a un fils qui hors du commun je
pense que tout le monde est capable et
capable de le voir maintenant qu'elle
est une tendance à vouloir absolument
tout contrôler nous l'anecdote qu'on
raconte elle est liée à l'affaire
Amraoui Diallo ou un moment elle s'est
elle était proche de Dialo mais elle est
partie au bon moment quand elle a vu que
ça puait cette histoire-là tu penses que
Killian il peut partir du PSG ou pas a
priori je vois pas je vois pas quel club
est capable de lui donner autant
d'argent que lui donne le PSG en ce
moment je vois pas bien ou alors il va
falloir qu'il accepte d'être beaucoup
moins payé après moi je pourrais
comprendre franchement dans un club qui
est aussi mal géré au bout d'un moment
on en a marre un peu ouais mais ça va ça
va ouais
la dernière on leur a reproché l'année
dernière on leur a reproché d'être
éliminé contre le Real Madrid oh ils ont
gagné la Ligue des champions cette année
on leur a reproché d'être éliminé bon
c'est vrai que cette année les blancs
c'est des chèvres mais les Bayern c'est
des chèvres je le dis c'est vrai on l'a
vu hier ils ont pris 3 - 0 contre les
laisser insensible Nassera la fille je
suis super bien pas là hein très bien au
foot aussi et joue avec lui il est
incroyable je le défendrai toujours ici
le PSG est aujourd'hui un grand club
parce que ça reste un grand club tu sais
moi ce que je joue à quoi je vois que le
PSG est un grand club quand les autres
équipes de Ligue des champions sont
contre le PSG au tirage au sort et bah
ils ont peur du PSG avant on avait pas
peur avant on n'avait pas peur du PSG tu
vois ou pas et je vais te dire moi j'ai
un j'ai une théorie je pense qu'il faut
qu'il fasse part d'une part d'une
feuille blanche tu vois mais quand je
dis une feuille blanche c'est feuille
blanche
non non moi je parle de les joueurs je
parle d'une feuille blanche ici je
repars à zéro tu veux que tu t'y connais
non mais quand je dis follement quand je
dis feuille blanche c'est feuilles
blanches
moi je te l'ai déjà dit mille fois je
lui donne même pas non plus
un centime juste le resto il me paye le
restant deux heures je lui fais son club
je veux même pas qu'il me pèse
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vraiment et tout ce qui
gravitent autour de lui
je te dis c'est le ménage aussi
que ça va et c'est un ami est vraiment
je le défendrai toujours le service
c'est vraiment un ami proche et on
s'aime beaucoup voilà après chacun pense
qu'il veut mais voilà
le défaut de mal s'entourer c'est tout
ah bah alors bah merci pour moi
la décision concernant
que ça sera avec plaisir en tout cas